يا عمي مشان الله مشان الله يا الشعب
العربي اقفوا معنا نادونا احنا بدنا
تقوموا تقوموا معنا اعملوا لنا حل اعملوا
لنا حل يا جماعه الخير احنا احنا عرب زينا
زيكم دمنا دمكم اقفوا معنا هبوا معنا وقفه
عرب وقفه عرب احنا بناشد بالله ثم فيكم
بناشد بالله ثم فيكم بناشد بالله ثم فيكم
كل ضمير حي يقف مع الشعب العربي احنا كل
يوم بنكت احنا كل يوم بنموت يا عم معيا ده
صغير انا امبارح شردنا من منطقه لمنطقه
طلعت مع بنتي صار معها صرع صرعي واولادها
ايش ايش نسوي ايش نعمل لما بتشوف الصغيره
بتيجي في من نتفي لنتف وين نروح يا جماعه
الخير احنا ما بدنا اكل امن بالله انا
الاكل من الصبح من ما اكلتش مش جابنا
الاكل ولا المي ما بدناش اكل يا جماعه
مشان الله اقفوا مع الاطفال غزه اطفال غزه
بتموت مش عشان الكبار في السن مشح وطين يا
يا عم خلي انسانيه انسانيه مشان الله اللي
عنده انسانيه في الشعوب العربي في الاكبار
يقف معنا هبه مشان الله بنقوله مشان الله
يقف معنا هبه وقفه شعب عربي بس اكتر من
هيك
ماج